hey 42 here every year forbes compiles a
list of the most powerful people on
earth based on the amount of human and
financial resources they have control
over as well as their influence on world
events let's reveal the top ten and more
importantly find out what makes them so
powerful first up at number 10 is David
Cameron
current Prime Minister of the United
Kingdom the United Kingdom is the sixth
wealthiest country on Earth which is
quite impressive when you consider its
relatively small size and population but
what really makes United Kingdom and
subsequently David Cameron so powerful
is its strong relationship with some of
the most powerful and wealthiest nations
on earth such as Iran Canada New Zealand
Australia and most of Europe what our
course the UK's closest ally is the
United States of America the two nations
have a special relationship seriously
that's actually what it's called the two
countries share intelligence military
and their economies the UK is also one
of the few countries that has active
nuclear weapons in the form of their
fearsome nuclear Trident program a chunk
of David Cameron's power was almost lost
in 2014 when Scotland came close to
gaining independence in the Scottish
referendum but voters narrowly kept
Scotland as part of the UK retaining
Cameron's number 10 spot at number nine
is a joint entry from the world of
business both tied for ninth place of
the founders of search engine giant
Google Sergey Brin and Larry Page their
company Google is unarguably the most
influential company of the digital era
maintaining the majority share in
search google has the unbelievable power
being able to curate the internet Google
are also buying up big companies left
right and center in fact since 2001
Google has purchased companies at a rate
of one per month most notably YouTube
double-click nest and Makani power
Google also owns the Android mobile
operating system more than a billion
devices around the world run the
software they also have their highly
secretive Google X research labs which
is responsible for bringing future
technologies to the present day such as
self-driving cars
Google glass and more recently their
calico program which is working on
curing diseases such as cancer and
Alzheimer's and massively extending
people's lifespans at eight is Mario
Draghi hilariously nicknamed Super Mario
is the president of the European Central
Bank it's easy to see where all his
power comes from when you consider that
he is in charge of a company that
manages the economies and financial
unities across 18 different countries in
Europe which is the world's wealthiest
continent it's also worth noting that
mario was previously managing director
of goldman sachs international at number
seven is Microsoft founder Bill Gates
there's no arguing with his place on
this list since he is the wealthiest
person in the world worth an estimated
seventy six billion dollars but good old
Bill Gates is using his power in the
best possible way since 2000 his charity
the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation
has given an astonishing 30 billion
dollars to charity making him the most
generous philanthropist in history he
has also inspired hundreds of other
wealthy individuals to donate their
fortunes to charity at six is Janet
Yellen
she is head of the Federal Reserve Bank
the central bank of the United States
arguably the most influential bank in
the world with 4.4 eight trillion
dollars in assets she is the first
female to hold a prestigious position
next up is Angela Merkel she is
Chancellor of Germany Germany is an
economic powerhouse and the fourth
wealthiest country in the world being
head of the German government also gives
her tremendous power over the rest of
Europe most recently she has been using
her enormous power to fight back against
Isis and to deter Russia's threats
against the Ukraine at number four is
the spiritual leader to one-sixth of the
world population that 1.2 billion people
Pope Francis possibly the most
open-minded leader of the Roman Catholic
Church to date he shocked the world when
he said that the theories of evolution
under the Big Bang are true and he made
history when stating Who am I to judge
when asked about his views on
homosexuality up-3 is asian Ping leader
of the three major parties of China the
Communist Party of China the People's
Republic of China and China's Central
Military Commission he is informally
referred to as China's paramount leader
essentially making him leader of the
world's second wealthiest country China
some say he is the most powerful Chinese
leader since Mao Zedong at 2 is Barack
Obama officially the most famous person
on this list Obama is the 44th and
current President of the United States
and the first African American to hold
the position the route of his power is
quite simple America is the wealthiest
nation on earth with a GDP of seventeen
point five trillion dollars it
also has the world's largest and most
deadly military as well as ties to a
handful of other powerful countries
despite all his power he has been
rapidly losing support amongst the
American people during his second term
in office because of a handful of events
but most notably Obama has increased the
national debt of the United States by
almost 70 percent since he took office
but the United States remains the
world's most influential nation easily
justifying Obama's place on this list
and finally at number 1 is Vladimir
Putin Vladimir is the president of
Russia the largest country in the world
by landmass he has a remarkable grip on
power he became prime minister of Russia
in 1999 switching between presidents and
prime minister in the year since
eventually settling on president in 2012
effectively making him leader of Russia
for the past 16 years but what makes
butan more powerful than Obama
well when Obama wants to make an
important change he has to drag his feet
through Congress Putin on the other hand
can pretty much do whatever he wants
when he wants
he heavily exercised this enormous power
throughout 2014 most notably annexing
Crimea starting a proxy war in Ukraine
and landing a seventy billion dollar gas
pipeline deal with China which keeps
European energy in a frustrating
chokehold basically whenever leaders
such as David Cameron and Barack Obama
want to exercise their power they have
to fight their way through hordes of
political hurdles Putin simply does what
he pleases and when he does decide to
exercise that power it's usually an
enormous leap our phul and controversial
act that makes headlines worldwide
thanks for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2
Oh